Hello Freak bitches.
The more view,
the better.
It's just going to make people want to
see.
But it was funny.
Fucking shit.
It was funny.
It's crazy.
We were having.
You were doing that.
Sorry I was filming at the store.
You were doing that fucking years and
years and years and years ago.
You do little sketches.
No.
Well I want to take all that stuff now
and just cut it up and do like little
three minute things and put it on funny
or die stuff because everybody was.
You were in it.
Everybody has it.
Everybody played a part.
But you do what?
The foreign comic Bronie we'd call them
the foreign comic,
you know,
and it was just these crazy EPA.
I remember you coming over to me one
night and you guys.
Can I ask you something?
Because I was using the comedy store
like a set I'd be filming.
I changed all the lighting in the
kitchen.
I put the red lights,
blue lights fulfilling.
I was doing it for a year and the cut
and waitresses would come in to get like
drink orders and I go,
I can have you in right now.
We're filming.
You can't be.
You're in my shot and everybody's asking
like managers,
like,
what show is this?
There was no show,
but everybody was in it.
Steve Reynolds was in it.
My black was my book.
I've become friends with my fucking
black,
so for whatever we use,
I come over to this guy,
he's sitting in the booth in the kitchen
and I go,
Hey Mike,
you want you want to be in the show?
And he's going,
what you?
I go,
it's,
it's a reality show.
And reality wasn't really happening yet.
It just wasn't happening.
So people like,
well,
what is I go,
you just do what I tell you to dope.
Just say what I tell you to say and do
whatever I said.
So whenever he goes,
yeah,
I want to be in it,
you know,
I go,
okay,
we're going to go to the top of the
belly,
the belly room,
the steps,
and I'm going to throw you down the
steps.
Okay?
And I got to get a couple of angles so
we'll have to do it two or three times.
And he goes,
wait a minute.
He goes,
what do you mean you're going to throw
me down the steps?
I go,
yeah,
from the top.
So you just go with it,
you know,
just fall down the steps.
And he goes,
I don't want you to do that to me.
Like A,
why not?
What's the big deal?
It's what you do.
He goes,
what do you mean?
It's what I do.
I go,
aren't you a stunt man?
And he goes,
where did you hear that echo?
The comics told me that that's what you
do besides comedy,
you're a stunt.
He goes,
I'm not a stunt man.
I don't want to be thrown down.
I want to be in it,
but I can't have you just taught me down
a full flight of steps like that.
I'm going to get hurt,
so we had to do with the pieces which I
like a fake fall.
Well,
no,
he would go like halfway and then I go
to the bottom of the steps to get the
rest of the fall and then I tried to
kill him with a chair and Ari Shaffir
jumps on me at the right moment to stop
me from killing this guy.
It was so I could do launch just so I
could a line from a bronx tale where I'm
on top of them now and I go,
I did this to you.
And he goes,
what will that mean?
I go,
don't worry about it.
When it's edited,
you'll see the whole series.
The image.
Yeah.
I got a job doing what I tell you to go
over to comics and go right,
look that way and enforced second.
Say That guy's gonna have a fucking
problem.
And he goes,
but there's nobody today.
I go,
don't worry about that part.
They'll be somebody on the other end and
another time and that's how I would
piece though.
So I want to take these tapes.
Just have some,
some editor do like three minute because
it was,
I did it for for two years.
They come to my house for a barbecue.
It wound up fighting.
Eleanor gets into a fistfight with Steve
[inaudible] wife where he screamed and
knocked the shit out of a.
she's got her up against the garage
because she said eleanor like,
you know,
is,
is like the house is filthy,
you know,
in Illinois,
screaming at me in the kitchen,
go.
And she said that when I'm so fucking
nice to have,
I'll handle this right now in Illinois.
It comes out of the back yard now.
The comic sitting there don't notice is
going to.
And she goes,
hey bitch,
this is to Steve's wife.
Right?
And she chases a slams are against the
garage that's beaten.
The shit out of Illinois was a progress
is Mike Black and Dave Taylor and Steve
Simone and my own kids screaming Kela
just fucking kill hogs.
And the end of that episode is Dave
Taylor,
you know,
at night sitting around going,
do you understand?
Do you know why Ellen did that?
Because girls like tracy,
but taking guys like you from eleanor,
her life and everybody's good.
And Steve,
someones going.
Yeah.
The way eleanor was hitting a like you
could just feel it,
you know,
like raging bull.
Like she really wanted to damage.
Yeah,
it's hysterical.
That's why I wouldn't have barbecues
just to film.
It was nonstop and he comes over to me
at the store.
Like,
what are you doing exactly?
To show my show what show?
Where is it?
Where can I see it?
I don't know.
There'll be around.
Are you still have the footage?
All of it.
Hundreds of tapes.
How did he exhibit towers?